[Musica]
voglio chiedere un favore a tutte le
donne qui presenti in sala alzate la
mano se avete mai subito una
discriminazione sul lavoro
se magari durante un colloquio mi hanno
chiesto se avete figli o salvate
intenzione di averne se magari avete mai
visto il vostro collega maschio ricevere
quel bonus o quella promozione magari
anche sarà meno bravo di voi o se
qualcuno vi ha mai fatto qualche battuta
un po fastidioso sessista o magari vi
anche ma è messo la mano da qualche
parte alzatevi la mano
alzate la mano se vi è mai successo
grazie
ad esso alzate la mano se qualcuno vi ha
mai insultato per il vostro aspetto
fisico se vi ha mai detto brutte grasse
troppo magre vecchie oppure se vi siete
mai sentite insicure del vostro corpo
magari vi siete vergognate di andare al
mare col costume alzate la mano
grazie
ad esso alzate la mano se a voi a una
vostra amica o una donna che conoscete
ha mai subito una qualsiasi forma di
violenza
se magari camminando per strada è stata
seguita da qualcuno sia stata toccata
senza la sua volontà se ha subito
violenza fisica psicologica sessuale
se mai subito un tentativo di stupro o è
stata stuprata o se è stata picchiata
alzate la mano
grazie
adesso vi chiedo se avete alzato la mano
almeno una volta
alzatevi in piedi al mio 31 23 alzatevi
siamo in tanti potete risiedervi grazie
ad esso vi do qualche dato
discriminazioni sul lavoro
meno di una donna su due è occupata il
50 per cento ha un contratto part time
la differenza salariale è del 12 per
cento
solo il 28 dei manager sono donne
il 9 per cento subito molestie o ricatti
sessuali sul lavoro
ci vorranno almeno 270 anni per
eliminare il gender gap a livello
globale
body shiming la metà delle donne subisce
insulti per il proprio aspetto fisico
la 85 per cento delle donne tra i 18 e
24 anni si sente insicura del proprio
corpo
il 96 per cento delle persone che
soffrono di disturbi alimentari sono
donne
violenza di genere
il 40 per cento delle donne ha subito
una forma di violenza fisica o sessuale
il 6 per cento ha subito uno stupro o
tentato stupro quasi 7 milioni di donne
tra i 16 70 anni hanno subito una forma
di violenza
ogni tre giorni una donna viene uccisa
come fanno sentire questi dati frustrate
indignate magari un po arrabbiate
ebbene non vi potete arrabbiare e vi
spiego il perché
questa è la propaganda che hanno fatto
agli inizi del novecento control e su
progetti le donne che chiedevano il
diritto di voto un diritto sacrosanto
l'origine lo sviluppo delle suffragette
a 15 anni un tenero animaletto a
vent'anni una civettuola a 40 anni non è
ancora sposata una stella
50 anni diventano suffragetta una donna
che chiede il diritto di voto una donna
che vuole farsi rispettare
nessuno mi chiama
nessuno mi vuole quindi diventerò una
suffragetta una donna che non vale
niente che nessuno vuole
vogliamo il voto ma solo brutta e
cattiva orrenda faccio schifo
mia mamma al nostro progetto al bambino
che piange per insinuare quel senso di
colpa delle donne che abbandonano i loro
figli se vogliono qualcosa di più
non sposate le suffragette voi uomini
altrimenti vi faranno fare i lavori di
casa lasciate le donne che vogliono far
sentire la propria voce che vogliono far
rispettare i propri diritti
adesso fredette sono cattive picchiano i
poveri uomini perché una donna che vuole
farsi rispettare e cattiva
questo è quello che farei a una
suffragetta la torturerei
se una donna che si lamenta 8 moglie si
lamenta usa questo aggeggio falla stare
zitta
alla fine la pace tagliamo la lingua le
donne facciamole stare zitte togliamogli
la loro voce
questo cadeva inizi del novecento in
inghilterra torniamo in italia il tempo
del fascismo
queste sono cartelle cliniche del
manicomio di sant'antonio abate a teramo
vi dico i sintomi per cui le donne
venivano chiusi i manicomi dell'epoca
dove di fatto che non torturate
loquace una donna che parlava veniva
messa in manicomio
nervosa
irritabile se una donna si arrabbia
viene messe manicomio insolente
irriverente
indocile una donna che non è docile e
che non subisce tutto ciò che l'uomo le
fa viene messa in manicomio
ebbene vi racconto una storia io dovrò
passeggiare soprattutto la sera dopo
cena abitavo a milano qualche anno fa e
come ogni sera arrestata e sono uscita a
farmi la passeggiata ero da sola in
pieno centro non zona tranquilla certo
punto arriva un uomo mi prende mi spinge
a posto il muro e tenta di fare
ovviamente senza il mio consenso e ho
cominciato a urlare fortunatamente mi
sono divincolata e sono riuscita a
scappare via
immaginate come mi son sentita non ce la
facevo più anche perché su vivo questo
tipo di molestie di ogni tipo ma tutti i
giorni da quando mi ricordi a essere
bambino ho chiamato una mia amica per
sfogarmi sono stata un'ora il telefono
un'ora in cui l'ho detto tutto chiuso la
telefonata non mi sono sentita bene ero
ancora arrabbiata aveva anche provato a
denunciare altri episodi non è successo
niente e ho detto qui anche se io mi
lamento con le mie amiche le cose non
cambieranno domani uscirà di casa avrò
ancora paura che qualcosa che potrà
accadere
sono tornata a casa quella sera che non
sono nati per la social però mi è venuto
spontaneo di aprire una pagina su
facebook
l'ho chiamata di getto a eva voice io ho
una voce perché era quello quello che io
volevo dire al mondo intero volevo dire
noi donne abbiamo una voce perché ci
volete sentire perché non possiamo
lamentarci perché non possiamo dire no a
una mozione a molestare
quella pagina ho continuato a scrivere
tutti i giorni raccontare storie di
donne un sacco di donne hanno
incominciato a seguirmi un sacco di
donne hanno incominciato a scrivermi
raccontarmi le loro storie un sacco di
donne hanno incominciato a chiedermi
aiuto un sacco di nonne hanno
incominciato a dirmi che volo lo
volevano aiutarmi per aiutare altre
donne e così abbiamo costruito una
grande comunità di donne che si aiutano
a vicenda che si danno forza che si
danno coraggio e io da tre anni a questa
parte dico tutti i giorni alle donne di
avere il coraggio di far sentire la
propria voce
una delle esperienze più belle che mi è
successo è stata l'anno scorso una
giovane donna di vent'anni mi ha
raccontato la sua storia e mi ha
raccontato che noi tutti i giorni per
tutte le domeniche da quando era bambina
andava al mare e prenderà sempre lo
stesso autobus in questa autobus c'era
uno dei quei vecchi bavosi credo che
tutte noi abbiamo avuto a che fare
e molestava tutte le ragazzine tutte le
domeniche nello stesso autobus tutte lo
vedevano tutte le conosceva nessuno gli
ha mai detto niente
passano gli anni la scoprì la mia pagina
ascolta quello che io le dico tutti i
giorni donne usate la vostra voce fatevi
rispettare quella domenica ha visto
quell'uomo che ho messo le mani addosso
una ragazzina si è rivista lei ha visto
che nessuno parlava e lei quel giorno ha
avuto il coraggio di usare la sua voce
ha insultato li hanno dette di ogni e ha
fatto bene sempre troppo poco lui sia
vergognato è sceso alla fermata dopo
dell'autobus non si è più fatto vedere
adesso immaginate se ogni donna facesse
sentire la propria voce ogni volta che
vedo che subisce una molestia un sopruso
una discriminazione per se stessa e per
le altre donne se lo facessimo tutte
tutti i giorni
pensate cosa potrebbe succedere non
potremo effettivamente cambiare il mondo
rewind che molestano le donne non
potrebbero iniziare a vergognarsi loro e
non noi a stare zitte
oggi sono qui per dirvi now questo io
voglio che accada nel mondo intero per
le donne voglio che le donne hanno il
coraggio di far sentire la propria voce
vogliono che abbiano il coraggio di
capire quanto forte può essere o no
quanto forte può essere un basta quanto
forte può essere io non voglio ho anche
io merito al lavoro io merito con la
promozione no non voglio che tu mi tocca
no lasciami stare quanto forte potrebbe
essere quando noi tutte facciamo questa
cosa quindi oggi voglio che voi vi
alzate impedì fate un gesto di forza un
pugno quello che volete e voglio che
dite a voi stessi al mondo intero i una
voce al mio tre alzatevi in piedi uno
due tre
io ho una voce io ho una voce grazie
[Musica]